lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
exponer les e introducirlos a la idea de
lo que es un programa de computadora y
espero que quieran continuar lo cual es
algo que recomiendo mucho porque
realmente la manera de aprender
computación es practicar y probar por
ustedes mismos
este es el entorno de payton así que voy
a estar haciendo mucha de la
programación en python y justo aquí el
entorno se llama pay scripture p&g scr y
pr es gratis es un software de código
abierto y estoy usando python creo que
estoy usando python 2.6 y 2.7 si ustedes
usan python 2 sus ejemplos serán iguales
que los míos trabajan de la misma manera
pero si usan python 3 van a tener que
hacer pequeñas variaciones para que
funcione correctamente y traten de tomar
notas cuando eso ocurra así que
empecemos escribiendo el programa lo que
es padre de esto es que podemos escribir
aquí un programa de computadora y lo que
realmente estamos haciendo es editando
un texto en un archivo es eso una serie
de instrucciones y la computadora va a
empezar desde arriba del archivo hacia
abajo a leer las instrucciones aunque
más tarde veremos que hay manera de
decirle a la computadora que salte por
ahí que haga ciclos de instrucciones una
y otra vez o que omita algunas cosas
escribamos un programa simple y mientras
hacemos esto estaremos revisando algunos
de los conceptos básicos de programación
así que voy a escribir un programa muy
simple un programa simple de computadora
sería literalmente una expresión déjenme
escribir imprime print 3 + 7 la
computadora literalmente va a sumar 3 +
7 e imprimirlo le va a pasar la suma a
la función print que viene con python
tal vez debo escribir print 37 déjenme
salvar este archivo así que literalmente
es una sola instrucción aquí en la línea
de arriba la instrucción es sprint 3 + 7
y clark o pondré otra instrucción para
que puedan ver
recorre de arriba hacia abajo déjenme
añadir otra instrucción imprime print
2 - 1 y también dejen de poner print
este es un ejemplo de texto
ejemplo de texto y veamos qué es lo que
el programa de computadora va a ser voy
a salvarlo como el archivo test área p y
lo que nos dice esta extensión
es que es un archivo de payton ahora
dejen de correr el programa algo padre
de este entorno de desarrollo en inglés
y del entorno de desarrollo integrado es
que puedes escribir tu programa y
correrlo en el mismo lugar también
colorea el código así que puedes ver
cuál es una función puedes ver los
diferentes tipos de datos y vamos a
hablar sobre los tipos de datos más
adelante pero déjenme correr este
programa para ver qué pasa aquí vamos lo
corremos e imprime 10 luego imprime uno
luego imprime este es un ejemplo de
texto así que hizo exactamente lo que le
dijimos que hiciera en el orden
establecido evalúo primero 3 + 7 que es
igual a 10 y lo imprimió aquí luego
imprimió 2 - 1 le imprimió aquí y luego
imprimió este es un ejemplo de texto
una cosa que quiere introducir
anticipadamente es la idea de tipos de
datos así que cuando vieron este ejemplo
probablemente sintieron un hueco en el
estómago pero miren aquí hay algo un
poco diferente del 3 o 2 o 1 ó 7 y este
ejemplo de texto estos son números y
puedo ya saben puedo sumar números que
representan cantidades mientras que esto
representa un ejemplo de texto y su
intuición es correcta estos son
diferentes tipos de datos los 13 y los 7
y los unos son literales numéricas y en
este caso particular representan enteros
y este de acá es realmente un string que
será una palabra que escucharán mucho en
computación que se refiere a una cadena
de caracteres y en python podemos
preguntar cuál es el tipo de datos de
estas cosas así que podemos pasarlas a
la función type y entonces ahora debe
imprimir el tipo de 3 + 7 no sólo 10
probemos aquí si imprimiremos 2 menos
uno para mostrar la diferencia y después
imprimir el tipo de datos de este
ejemplo de text
déjenme salvarlo sólo teclear el control
ese que es el método abreviado para
salvar y tratar de correr este programa
aquí vamos el programa evalúa la
sentencia y para evaluar empieza por lo
que hay en el paréntesis 3 + 7 es 10 y
el tipo de datos de 10 es entero así que
imprime int y lo verán aquí es de tipo
entero int que es una forma corta de
interior después dice imprime dos menos
uno y el programa lo hace justo en esta
línea imprime uno y luego el primer tipo
de datos de toda esta cosa que está aquí
así que no le imprime completa solo
imprime su tipo de dato que es string
ahora la siguiente cosa que quiero
mostrar mientras le sigo explicando los
programas es la idea de una variable en
la que almacenar hemos cosas en lugares
diferentes y como veremos en futuros
vídeos de payton es como si tuviéramos
etiquetas en esas cosas y las etiquetas
pudieran cambiar de valor o como si
pudiéramos poner cosas en diferentes
tipos de etiquetas déjenme escribir un
programa completamente diferente aquí
arriba lo haré usando variables
lo que es padre de payton aunque algunos
no les gusta es que podemos poner
cualquier tipo de dato en cualquier tipo
de variable así que podemos decir que a
es igual a 35 y luego b es igual a
digamos a por a favor a menos a menos 1
y luego podemos decir que es igual a tal
vez a por ver a por b y luego podríamos
abrir un poco de espacio justo aquí para
que esto se vea un poco más limpio
se es igual a por b y luego podríamos
decir imprimir print se dejen imprimirse
y si quieren sigamos adelante y traten
de imaginar cuál será el resultado de
ese pero vamos a correr este programa y
luego vamos abajo a ver que realmente
hizo bien lo que le dijimos voy a salvar
este programa y lo voy a correr el
resultado de ese es 440 así que veamos
si tiene sentido 3 + 5 es 8 entonces la
variable a vale 8 por lo que en
cualquier lugar del programa hasta que
no redefinamos a el programa va a decir
oh ah es un 8 a vale 8 así que cuando
vamos abajo aquí y redefinimos ve el
programa dirá ok
8 por 8 teniendo en cuenta el orden de
las operaciones primero se hacen las
multiplicaciones especialmente cuando
las comparas con una resta así que 8 por
8 nos va a dar 64 y luego 64 menos 8 64
8 y 56 menos 155 así que ve el 55 y
luego se va a ser 8 por 50
5 y 8 por 55 es sin duda 440 todo
funcionó muy bien
probablemente ven esto y se preguntan
qué pasaría si tuviéramos a con un valor
diferente podemos intentarlo podríamos
cambiar lo que pasa aquí con un valor
diferente de a así que podríamos decir
que a es igual digamos que a un 6
negativo ahora corremos el programa a
ver qué pasa
obtuvimos menos 246 pueden verificarlo
por ustedes mismos si revisamos línea
por línea y tenemos estas variables con
el valor que hemos definido para ellas
podemos ver si obtenemos la respuesta
que está aquí ahora si los programas son
sólo un montón de comandos que se siguen
de arriba a abajo no podríamos hacer
realmente cosas interesantes así que
para hacer algo interesante vamos a
empezar a ver cosas como los
condicionales y los ciclos y un ciclo
condicional es algo así como déjenme
hacer esto voy a dejar estas cosas aquí
arriba y voy a decir si ya
es menor que cero entonces imprime ce
print si de otra manera
imprime menos a print se menos a esto se
ve interesante y probablemente ya se han
imaginado qué va a pasar aquí pero
déjenme salvarlo y es asombroso todo lo
que podemos hacer con sólo usar estos
condicionales aquí está a ya es menor
que cero hace esto si no hace esto que
está aquí así que el programa no correrá
de arriba a abajo sino que depende decía
es menor que cero no va a ejecutar esta
línea o va a ejecutar esta otra línea y
la manera en que payton va a ejecutar
solo esta línea que si a es menor que
cero y está intentado aquí y esto es
parte de la condición y la manera de
saber que hay una instrucción para esta
condición son estos dos puntos y
entonces si esta condición no se cumple
o se hacía no es menor que cero
payton va a ejecutar esta otra condición
else si ustedes quieren hacer algo
adicional independientemente de si a es
menor que cero no sólo salgan de la
condición y escriban la instrucción sin
intentar así que ahora podemos imprimir
con el programa print terminamos con el
programa
dejen agregar algo a esta instrucción
imprime print a es menor que cero
observen esto no va a ser evaluado
tenemos esto escrito aquí dentro de un
string así que solo va a imprimir esto y
luego aquí abajo vamos a imprimir a no
es menor que cero
bueno es un programa interesante
corramos el programa muy bien esperemos
que corra los salvó y corre el programa
y vemos que imprimió a es menor que cero
así que corrimos el programa imprimió a
es menor que cero hizo lo que está
dentro de esta condición y entonces
imprimió sé que es menos 246 y no
ejecutó estas instrucciones que se van a
ejecutar solos ya no es menor que cero y
luego sale de la condición e imprime
terminamos con el programa ahora
cambiamos el valor de a para ver si
podemos hacer que esta otra condición se
cumpla así que hacemos a mayor que cero
vamos a hacer igual a nueve déjenme
correr el programa
ahora corremos el programa de 9 a es
menor que cero bueno 9 no es menor que
cero así que no va a ejecutar estas
instrucciones y se va a ir a las
instrucciones de la condición efe
y va a imprimir a no es menor que cero
lo que hizo aquí después imprimió se
menos a imprimió se menos saque 630
entonces sale de la condición decía es
menor que será o no e imprime terminamos
con el programa